Dear Diary,
Today was the day — my first day at my new school!
Come on, we need a pic!
A selfie or something.
It was so exciting, I don’t even know where to start!
First of all, it’s a lot fancier than my old school.
The pool is bigger than the school!
It’s an elite academy, and my classmates are the sons and daughters
of some of the most important people in the country!
I'm doing my best to be an idol!
I hear your family runs
a successful toy company.
They do.
Just think about it:
I’m surrounded by
future politicians and business leaders.
When your name is Nadia Shanaa,
you'd better be informed of
what can get you expelled.
Just in case.
The entire school is so beautiful, like a university campus,
and we all wear these super stylish uniforms.
It’s like something out of a fairy tale.
To be honest,
I was a bit nervous about going to school here.
What's up, people? I'm Christian.
Look at this guy.
There were some rumors about how they
treat transfer students.
Okay, according to you,
you're saying it's the new students that are at fault?
When a different species is introduced into an ecosystem,
it disrupts it.
But so far, everyone’s been nice!
Take home the win!
Score!
I even hung out with them after school.
Hey, would you like to come to a party
at my place tomorrow night?
Maybe you'd like to do a little
gambling with me?
It doesn’t seem like anything could go wrong!
I'm going to step down as president,
and we'll arrange an election to choose another one.
Dear Diary,
I’ve been at my new school for a week now, and,
well, let’s just say there have been a couple of hiccups.
No, that's just...
I mean, for one thing, my classmates
have some really complicated relationships!
It’s hard to keep up with who’s dating who, who owes who what,
and who’s where on the pecking order.
Mittens!
I feel like I’m spending more time studying
the social structure than I am on my classwork!
This should be a ten.
And some of the stuff going on is pretty intense!
If I can't pay back what I owe,
I'll truly become a house pet.
Over the past week, I’ve realized there’s
a lot of drama going on behind the scenes.
Gambling...
Theft...
Drugs...
What about the police?
We're just three innocent students.
Sex...
Violence...
-Don't!
-Stop!
Get the fuck out of my school!
Everyone seemed so nice and well-adjusted at first,
but it turns out being rich doesn’t solve all your problems.
What the hell is this?
In fact, it seems to create quite a few.
I don't have a price tag.
And trust me, if I did, you couldn't afford it.
This is a massacre.
I've already surrendered three billion yen.
My status as a student council member...
destroyed!
I cannot allow that to happen!
One more thing, diary:
I’m feeling a lot of pressure from my classmates to act like them,
and get involved in some pretty dangerous stuff.
We need to get rid of that blood. Come here.
I want to fit in, but I don’t want to change who I am…
What should I do?
If it must be.
I wager my life in return.
Dear Diary,
After a lot of soul searching, I’ve finally decided.
It seems so obvious now.
Why should I hold back? Why resist?
Why deny myself the opportunity I’ve found here?
I’m not just going to embrace the high-stakes lifestyle.
I’m going to rise to the top!
They thought they could bully me.
Now, they're freaking out.
Drugs, crime, gambling.
I’ll do anything to show the world who’s best!
To earn my classmates’ respect—no, fear!
To become... an elite!